خارج الخطوط هناك منافسه اخرى بين وليد
الرجراجي مدرب المغرب ودي شامبو مدرب
فرنسا ولذرك راجي الذي يملك ثماني مباريات
وليا فقط مع منتخب المغرب يواجه الذي قاد
فرنسا في 2737 مباراه وحقق معهم كاس
العالم رجلاجي يتحدث منذ بدايه عن عقليه
الانتصار وان تكون غايه اللاعبين هي تتويج
وينصب النجاح الذي يحققه الجيل الحالي لهم
وحدهم المدرب المغربي يقول الانتقادات
اداء هو قلت استحواذ فريقه نابعه من
الانزعاج بسبب وصول منتخب افريقي لنصف
النهائي مدرب فرنسا يتحدث بالتواضع ايضا
عن المغرب ويرى انهم يستحقون المكان التي
وصلوا اليها في المونديال واقر بصعوبه
التسجيل امامهم وذلك بسبب صلابتهم
الدفاعيه لكنه سيحاول حل ذلك ورغم انه قاد
منتخب مصر
المونديال السابق الا انه قد يصبح تحيه
جديده في حال خسارته امام المغرب وربما
يواجه شبح الايقال لا غير روبيرتومات مدرب
برجيكا ولوس امريكا مدرب اسبانيا